montceau-les-mines vit sa première nuit
sous couvre-feu
près d'une quarantaine de crs kadri la
ville ce soir les identités sont
vérifiées les habitants du quartier de
la sablière assistent à la scène
malgré ces renforts ils n'ont toujours
pas l'esprit serein bah on surveille on
dort pas on entend un bruit on a peur
voilà les enfants tout le monde la
famille voilà quoi on est constamment
sur nos sons nous gardons voilà comme
vous voyez on reste dehors on surveille
on guette jusqu'au moment où on va on va
tomber sur eux et c'est malheureux à
dire mais c'est ce qu'on va devoir faire
justice eux-mêmes quoi l'aîné de la
famille tient à nous montrer l'ampleur
des dégâts à plusieurs reprises les
pyromanes se sont infiltrés dans leur
intimité
ça c'était le 9 septembre exactement la
deuxième partie du garage
là aussi qui a qualité qui a été touché
cette table étaient sur la terrasse avec
des chaises et la police municipale est
arrivée à temps avec un extincteur pour
pouvoir maîtriser le feu donc
heureusement que sa part a pris parce
que tout en charpente est fait est fait
en bois un abri de jardin qui était
déplacé ici instant droit même que vous
voyez donc là c'est que dassault il y
avait des habitudes matériel du matériel
de jardinage y avait pas mal de choses
donc une fois ces sans abri de jardin le
3c garage
après c'est la table maintenant c'est
les poubelles va bientôt ce sera lui
qu'on va cramer
l'exaspération on la trouve aussi dans
les quartier du bois-du-verne ces deux
jeunes de 20 ans pense connaître les
auteurs de ces incendies des ados qui
cherche juste à s'occuper seulement
parce qu'il y en ait beaucoup ça passe à
la télé tout ça sinon d'habitude se
passe pas à la télé mais il ya tout le
temps et tout temps une voiture qu'ils
croient des jeunes de maintenant ils
font cours moi j'étais je ne suis jamais
fait ça n'avait jamais craint une
voiture pourtant ça fait neuf ans jeudi
au quartier jamais ramené voitures de
nos vies lors ces petits labaki
l'affairé dit que je sais pas où qu'ils
aillent faire l'armée ça irait mais
dross le retour à l'ordre un espoir pour
la plupart des habitants de montceau les
mines